So I'm, I'm really pleased
to introduce Dr John Barge.
He's a professor of
psychology at Yale University.
He's been doing research in this field
for over 25 years, much longer than that.
Even with a focus on the unconscious.
He's distilled key findings from his
research in the field in general into the
book that he's here to talk about today.
Before you know it,
the unconscious reasons we do what we do,
please join me in giving him,
giving him a warm welcome.
[inaudible]
thank you David.
Thank you all for coming.
I know you have an option
during your lunch. Don't
shower, don't have to be here.
So I appreciate it.
Um,
so the book is not about
the Freudian unconscious.
It's a about the last 30 or 40 years of
actual systematic scientific research on
average normal people randomly
assigned to conditions, uh, not,
uh, uh, case studies of
mentally ill people, uh,
from which a Freud generate and generated
a, it's an entire theory. Uh, it's also,
um, we'll see the talk is
sort of structured this way,
but it's only a 30 minutes.
And I'm actually,
if you'd like,
I'll try to speed it up and
make it shorter than that.
Uh, it's also not a, um,
uh, what we found is that logically
you probably would figure this out.
It's not a separate mind. Unconscious is
not some kind of separate part of the,
of the brain with its own rules and with
its own operating system on, on, uh,
and it's locked away and you can't see it.
You probably,
you remember that movie inside out with
the little emotions running a control
room, that animation movie, one of the
little emotions did something wrong.
It got thrown into this unconscious
cave and the door was locked.
He never saw them again.
I never heard from them again.
And that's not what we're talking about.
It's a,
it's a very different kind of thing.
It's, it's one, uh, brain, uh,
the research showing a affects of
increasing or decreasing incentives during
tasks. This is out of university college.
London, uh, shows at the same brain.
Regions are, are, are
used, uh, become active.
In either case when a
motivational state as a,
a conscious one or it's
an unconscious one,
it's the same brain region and that's
pretty much true of everything.
Whatever the kind of a thing
you're looking at, emotion,
motivation, a language,
behavior.
It's the same part of the brain that's
operating and whether it's in conscious
or unconscious mode,
but it's a single unified brain.
It's basically I help the unconscious.
Unconscious influences are generally
helpful. They survived natural selection,
they survived evolution. They're
not some kind of destructive, evil,
evil twin lurking inside your skull.
So that's the difference between what
a lot of people here and the word
unconscious. And that's what they,
they think of. Of course. Well,
there's a disconnect though and
this is why, uh, I'm organizing, uh,
organize the book but also organize
this talk today in terms of the past,
present, and future, because we're
focused almost always on the present.
We're focused on what's around,
what's going on in front of us,
what we are aware of, right?
What else could we be aware of,
but what we're aware of. And so we
understand the reasons for how we feel.
And our decisions and and so forth based
on what's available to us right now in
front of us, the mind is on all
three times zones at the same time.
You could influence this from the
evolutionary past, very strong ones.
You've got influences
from your early childhood.
You have no memory for any more from your
first three or four years of life that
carry over the rest of your life.
Influences of your recent past,
which just happened. The carryover,
like for my case for a long time,
my work life would just segue right
into my home life and carry over to my
understanding of what was going
on at home, which was wrong. Uh,
but also your future, your motivations,
your goals, your aspirations,
things you're trying to attain, whether
it's a longterm life goal, have a family,
have a successful career, be happy,
uh, that kind of thing. Or even just,
I got to get something done tomorrow.
Your mind is often in the future. Uh, and,
and your goals and motives influenced
how you see the present. In other words,
what's good for your goal?
It's what's good for you.
And you like and dislike things as a
function of whether they're good for your
current goal,
which can be a disconnect from your
longterm values and your longterm beliefs.
And I'll show you some examples of that.
So that's how it's organized
and we'll jump right in, um,
to the distant past of evolutionary
past and these basic needs,
uh, these, these very important, uh,
needs that we have and motivations that
we have. So basic to be safe, to survive,
not to die, to avoid
disease, to avoid germs,
protect ourselves against disease. Uh, and
of course, reproduction and mating, sex,
uh, and cooperation. And these are, these
are the basic ones, but they're, you know,
they're the basic physical motivations
that we have. And yet, as you'll see,
they're influencing a lot more than that.
So for example,
this is topical because this is October.
It seems like every October
we're told to get out, you know,
go out and get a flu shot.
There's this horrible new strain of flu
virus out there. Uh, that's a killer and,
and very dangerous. Can't read this very
well. I'll tell you the, the study though,
there's a metaphor is being used in our
country and it's actually a metaphor
that's been used in the past by arch
conservative leaders in the past that is
tapping into this very strong motivation
that we have without realizing it.
That immigrants into a country are like
viruses into a body like germs into a
physical body or bacteria into a body.
And we need to protect ourselves and
be safe from these germs and bacteria.
We have to expel them and get rid of
them if they're in our body already.
We have to build walls or build
structures to keep them out,
protect ourselves from the invasion of
these germs and bacteria into our Bobby.
And so if you think about, uh, uh,
immigrant immigration that way, there's a,
you can see there's a strong connection
between the metaphor or analogy of
immigration into a country and germs
or bacteria or viruses into a body.
Not said explicitly,
although people,
arch conservative leaders in the past
have said that explicitly about despised
minority groups in their
society. Uh, and it,
it was an excuse or justification for
eradication of those groups. Well,
what do we do this time of year?
A few years ago,
we reminded the people in our study of
the flu virus and the threat of the flu.
And then we had them complete a attitude
survey about immigration attitudes
towards immigration.
After that,
we asked them after they'd
already completed that survey,
whether they'd had a flu shot or not.
So the people who we raised this threat
but already knew they had a flu shot,
felt safe because here's the threat.
But they've already taken steps
to protect themselves against it.
They should feel safe from the flu virus.
It turns out they had more positive than
average attitudes towards immigration
because we raised the fruit,
the flu threat.
But for the people we raised the flu
threat too, but had not had the flu shot.
Their attitudes towards immigration
became significantly more negative.
They were more against immigration
compared to a control group.
So we're moving around their attitudes
towards immigration by raising and
lowering the threat of the
flu virus, which is that
connection I'm talking about.
And there's more, there's a longstanding
lot of research, uh, showing that,
um, conservative, uh, uh,
people with conservative ideologies are
conservative attitudes are generally
more concerned with physical
threat and physical safety.
Then other people are a lot of
research on that. For example,
the size of the human,
the Amygdala,
which is the part of the brain that
reacts to fear and, and strong emotions.
It's actually larger and
conservatives than in liberals.
Brain imaging studies have shown that
four year olds who are more fearful tend
to have more conservative attitudes
at age 23 as a study out of Berkeley.
So there's lots of studies on
this and in general, given this,
there's been a easy trick that a political
psychologist have used in the past
that you can turn a liberal
into a conservative basically
by threatening them,
making them feel afraid. They then
have more conservative attitudes.
And remember Franklin
Delano Roosevelt saying,
we have nothing to fear but fear itself.
And former president Obama talks a lot
these days about against the politics of
fear because fear makes
people more conservative.
Well,
people have always turned,
have been very successful at turning
liberals and the conservatives,
but no one has ever turn a
conservative into a liberal.
And so we did that by,
as you probably could figure out
how having him feel physically safe.
We had them imagine that they were given
a super power by a genie and they was a
rich imagination exercise.
And they really are trying to really
imagine this happening in the control
condition. The super power they
were given was to be able to fly.
That's actually the most
popular superpower people
want of all the ones that are
possible. That's a control
condition. The others were, uh,
given the superpower of being
invulnerable from FIS to physical harm,
like superman bullets would bounce off
you if you fell. Nothing would happen.
Nothing would cut you. Those kinds
of things. And they imagined that.
And then we looked at their attitudes on
standard social issues that classically
define and divide conservatives
and liberals, like same
sex marriage, marijuana,
legalization and so forth.
The ones that are the standard ones where
you got the difference and you see on
the left the flying condition,
you get the standard difference.
Conservatives are more
conservative than liberal,
but the fly thing didn't
matter at all as a superpower,
but the people who were made
to feel and vulnerable to harm,
the Conservatives move much more,
much more close to liberal attitudes
as a result of feeling physically safe
temporarily.
Another study on the actual defining
quality of being conservative,
which is resistance to social change.
That's what the,
that's what FDR was talking about in that
speech about fear and fear itself was
talking about the new deal
that wasn't about World War II.
That was 1933 his first state of the
Union address during the depression
on that issue, you actually
cause conservatives in
the roads to be identical.
If anything,
then you've taken conservatives and
turned them into liberals by at least
temporarily making them feel
totally physically safe.
Just like you can take liberals,
make them more conservative in their
attitudes by making them feel afraid.
So these deep underlying evolved needs
bubble up to influence, you know,
abstract social attitudes and political
attitudes that you think are just the
product of reasoning and
some reason position.
But you can raise or lower
those conservative liberal
attitudes on the top of
the boiling water bite.
Uh,
the underlying flame underneath of feeling
physically safe or feeling physically
afraid. Another one has been
a lot of research on this one.
Physical warmth and coldness
over the last 10 years or so.
We did a study 10 years ago in science
published in science where essentially we
gave everybody the same at uh,
at Yale and other places,
the same description of a person to read.
And they formed an impression of
whether they liked the person or not.
We gave everybody the same one,
but for some of them while
they were coming into the
experiment, actually in the,
in the elevator coming up to lab,
we had a lot of papers,
like the question they were,
they were supposed to fill out and we had
in our hand, oh here we even have one,
uh, a couple of either ice coffee or, or,
or hot coffee, iced coffee or warm coffee.
This is the ice coffee condition.
Okay.
We said, could you hold that
for me for a second, you know,
so I can get your papers for you.
And they hold it and open it,
throws the papers and
he took it right back.
So it was a matter of
two or three seconds.
They might've held but warm
or the hot or the ice coffee.
If they held a warm coffee,
they formed a significantly more positive
impression of the person they read
about.
If they had held the ice
coffee significantly more
negative impression of the
person they read about number.
Everybody read the about the same person.
So feeling physically warm or cold
actually changed it or feeling of a person
being socially warm or socially
cold. And since then, last 10 years,
it's been a lot of neuroscience on this,
mainly at Ucla
where they show the same little
part of the human insula,
which is a walnut shaped part of the
brain and the middle of the brain.
The same little part becomes when you
hold something warm and when you're
texting your family and friends and when
you're thinking about the people close
to you.
And also the same little part becomes
active when you hold something cold and
when you're thinking about people
who had betrayed you, who are,
who are your enemies? They're
connected, they're wired together.
There's a channel between feeling
physical warmth and feeling trust and,
and the positive things
towards other people.
And the same kind of channel conversely
with, with feeling of physically cold,
get back to that in a second.
Much more other research has been
showing that a person's actual body
temperature goes up and down along with
their feelings of how closely feel to
their family and friends.
So people are in the hospital,
their temperatures taken oral temperature
every six, every hour for six hours.
And they also asked them how closely
feel to the close ones in their life.
And it tracks their body temperature,
raises and lowers when people are rejected
in some way and a little game when
people don't throw the ball to you
anymore and some computer game,
the avatars are tossing the ball around,
but they stopped throwing it to you.
You feel a little rejected.
Your,
your body temperature actually decreases
about 0.4 Fahrenheit of a degree.
You're actually feeling physical.
Your body is actually physically
colder after socially cold experience.
There was another kind of past,
maybe even more opaque to us because the
things that happened to us in the first
three, four years of life, we
don't have much memory for.
A lot of things happened to
us back then as as infants.
This is my daughter who's a now
11, but when she was, uh, one, two,
three years old,
she was a huge fan of the movie cars
and she loved lightning McQueen and she
drove around the house,
a little lightening cars that in a
lightning chair had a lightning blanket.
And we watched that movie
together 50 or 60 times,
at least 50 or 60 times.
She was obsessed with lightening
McQueen thought lightening,
lightening McQueen live nearby in Durham,
Connecticut cause she's a red
corvette and you know, in that town,
Nixon next door we lived.
Well then she became five and a one
night she wanted to watch a movie.
And I said, okay, Whoa, Whoa,
why don't we watch cars?
We haven't seen that for a while, several
years, you know, and, and uh, that was,
you know, you love that movie.
It was your favorite movie.
And she looked at me like I was nuts.
Like, no, I've never heard of that movie.
I'd never seen it before. And she really
had no memory of ever seeing it before.
And she's telling me this,
sitting in that same lightning McQueen
chair that she's never heard of this
movie.
And we watched it and she really was like,
she was watching it for the first time.
It was like a surprise at all.
The plot twist. She was laughing
at the right places. But as this,
she'd never seen the movie before and
she thought I was crazy cause I had said
that she has just no memory at all
of those years of her life. Well,
why is that important?
Because there's a lot of things that do
happen early in our life that do matter
to the rest of our life and we have
no idea that they're influencing us.
And for one thing,
a research out of Minnesota has tracked
these people who are now in their
twenties. But, uh, when
they were one year old,
they came into the lab with
their mother and they, uh,
took what's called the strange test.
The strange test is a way to measure
how it taps the child is to the,
to the parent. And usually back in
the day it was always the mother.
But now it's both parents and their
kids, you know who are attached.
Mother leaves the room and they're
like not bothered because they know if
there's any problem other
we'll be right back.
They can count on that mother has their
back, but others they don't know that.
And so when the mother leaves
our are a mess, their cry there,
there's sterically because they know the
mother may not be coming back very soon
or may not come in if they're
yelling and crying for them.
So they can't trust that.
So it was a matter of bonding and trust.
Is it there at age one or not?
Then they look at these people age six,
seven in elementary school,
high school, then in their twenties,
if they're securely attached to,
they have more friends in
grade school, they have, uh,
they're happier and do better grades in
high school and they have relationships
that do not break up very
often in their twenties.
The opposite is true of the people who
have insecure relationships at age one
with their mother. So something
is happening early in your life.
It's affecting your relationships
with people. Can you trust people?
Do you break up with them easily
or not the rest of your life?
And they're tracking these people now
they will continue to track them as they
go through their life.
But that's totally opaque to you because
you have no memory of any of that.
Yeah.
There's things that happened
in the present to go beyond
what's really out there.
Uh, for example, we really think
we know people from their face.
We really think that their
faces, diagnostics, somehow
we really know that person.
No grumpy cat, right? It's a cat.
It's a cat hats. Really Grumpy, right?
I mean, it's not grumpy. It looks grumpy.
You think it's grumpy now it's a cat.
It's that really grumpy
boy. It looks grumpy, right?
And that's old man Marley from home alone.
You know, probably before your time,
but this is the 1990s
movie, right? Old Man.
Marlene was like an ax murderer and the
base bodies in the basement next door
according to the kids in the neighborhood,
but turned out to be the sweet old guy.
There's that scene at the end of the
Christmas and he reunites with his
granddaughter and it's all wonderful,
but he's a sweet guy. He is, looks like,
you know,
some ax murderer.
But we really feel so sure of
ourselves when we see a person's face.
Like we really know the personality. Turns
out that's not diagnostic. People are,
uh, elected, uh, uh, as,
as senators and governors who
have the most trustworthy pace,
people rate those faces
not knowing who they are.
And it turns out the one that was rated
Morse trustworthy and competent tends to
win these elections 70% of the time.
So certainly the people
voting are thinking,
they know this person's
competent are trustworthy,
and the face by itself is not diagnostic.
What is diagnostic is the person
in action. If you see a person,
even for 15 seconds,
30 seconds interacting with other people,
that does predict very well. Um, their
outcomes. Are they good therapists?
Are they good teacher? Are they a
good whatever, but not photographs?
And not just seeing a person for the
first time without any kind of interaction
or seeing them in action at all.
Yeah.
Here's another way we go beyond that. We
have hurts of antelopes schools of fish,
Fox of bird, all doing the same
thing. Same time. You know,
Fred bird is not looking around
seeing Susie bird go one way and say,
I think I'll do the same thing.
It's not,
it's not a matter of
making decisions here.
It's just an automatic kind of response
to do the same thing as the conspecifics
around you. Um, and cats,
I'm not so sure. I mean,
this needs to be replicated.
Um, but we do, people do,
people definitely do this. Little kids
really imitate, especially around age two,
age three, they're learning what
it is right to do. They don't know.
And so they're really watching everybody
to see and they'll do what you're doing
and they'll do it over
and over and over again.
Okay.
So we studied this and show them that
effecting the lab with college students,
a physical behaviors like holding
your ear, protecting your ear or,
or shaking your foot,
that kind of thing.
You're more likely to do it when you're
with a person doing the same thing and
you've switched people and you do with,
so it's like a chameleon changing
the spots to match the environment,
the social environment they're in.
Okay. But this has consequences.
This is a Dutch field study
showing that anti social behavior,
mild littering graffiti,
uh,
taking a shopping cart three blocks to
your car instead of not leaving it in the
parking lot.
Those kinds of mild anti social behaviors
are contagious in that in an area that
has no graffiti,
these leaflets that are put on the
handlebars of the bike by rubber bands are
not littered as much as
they are on the right.
They put these on and if there's
graffiti in that kind of thing,
there's much more littering throwing them
on the ground instead of throwing them
away. Uh, and the various demonstrations,
this paper came out in science about 10
years ago. Their social network analysis,
uh, Nick Christakis and Jim
Fowler, uh, looking at, uh,
social networks like alumni
associations or, or work groups, um,
uh, credit union members, this
kind of thing. And in that network,
who knows who things like
obesity, depression, cooperation,
happiness and other things spread
so that if there's a person,
two or three people removed from you,
but, and you don't even know them,
but they know somebody you know,
and that kind of thing,
you're much more likely to have the
same characteristics as they are.
So things like that spread
behavior spreads, mood spread,
a behavior types like cooperation spread,
that's contagion.
The [inaudible] probably
heard of this one, the,
the Facebook study from 2014 we're
700,000 users have their newsfeed
deliberately manipulate it
as an experiment to be 20%
more positive or 20% more
negative than usual.
And then they look to see that that
user's own posts three up to three or four
days later to see if they were also
more positive or more negative.
And they were so the
manipulate the newsfeed,
it actually caused the person themselves
to have more positive or more negative
mood in their posts.
That's another kind of,
obviously social network
could get this kind of spread.
What you see is what you do. Uh,
unfortunately is used by advertisers.
This is a epidemiological study
coming out of northeastern university,
just published last year about
1000, uh, underage drinkers,
13 to 19 years.
The more alcohol ads they watched on TV,
the more they drank. You see these
a lot, parents, uh, often, uh,
watch NFL football games or other
sporting events. You see beer ads,
you see a captain Morgan,
you see alcohol adds a lot.
The more of these ads the kids were
exposed to, the more of they drank.
And this goes from an average of 10
drinks a month to 30 drinks a month for
those who watched a lot of ads.
This is a direct effect of the ad content.
We've done studies just looking at five
minute comedy clips, uh, the old, uh,
show whose line is it anyway
with drew Carey, we have a,
a food add in there in the, in the break
or a non food add in there. In the break,
we have a bowl of goldfish crackers next
to him and the people who saw the food
ad,
it wasn't even about that kind of food.
Eight 45% more of the goldfish crackers.
The food ads are trying to get you to
eat at home when you're watching TV so
that you'll eat more than and have to
buy more the next day at the store.
They're trying to get
you to consume more here.
They're trying to get you to drink
more or at least that is the outcome.
Whether or not they are
deliberately trying to do that.
And the effect happens
to teenage drinkers too.
Nice thing about this mimicry is
that it actually causes bonding,
liking and a feeling of the interaction
went more smoothly. Um, you know,
we have these things where people
do the same thing at the same time.
And in our culture, religious
rituals where you stand,
you kneel, you sing hymns,
you all do it at the same time.
Military, you w you march in step,
you say things together in unison.
This actually does produce greater
bonding and liking for the group.
And the group effort. These are
fields studies. This is Dutch,
a restaurant and the waitress,
all the,
all the waitress or waiter did
in this study was to repeat back.
The customer's order is right afterwards.
So I like a hamburger,
a milkshake and some fries. Uh, please.
And then the waitress would say like
a hamburger, milkshake and fries.
Just repeat back the order or not.
If she repeated back the order,
the tips are on the right. They're
significantly more tips at the end, uh,
than otherwise. This is a
French department store. Uh, uh,
electronics department,
part of the French department store,
large French department store and MP,
three players here. The same thing.
They repeated back with the customer
said when they, I'd like, uh, uh,
look at an MP, three player for my
grandson. He's turning 13 next week. Oh,
you're like an MP,
three player for your grandson.
He's turning 13 next week or
not. Right. Or just, okay,
here's the MP. Three players.
Sales went from 63 to 87% in the a mimicry
condition and customer satisfaction
with the store.
And the clerk was markedly higher.
They went out to the parking lot and
ask those kinds of questions afterwards.
So real,
real life consequences.
Now the other thing about the
president is the context changes. You,
you can be a different person at home,
uh, as, as a, as you are at work.
Um, my, my,
my sister was actually at the talk I
gave in San Francisco the other day. Uh,
and we're looking at a show like this is
not our mother isn't who, yeah, it is.
This is our mother. Um, so you can be
a different person in different places.
Right? Well, Ernst Fehr,
who's a professor of economics
at the University of Zurich,
has actually been tipped to win a
Nobel prize in economics one day soon.
You might hear his name again, has done
studies looking at investment bankers.
Big thing in Zurich,
right?
So investment bankers might be a different
people at work than they are at home.
What he did was to get them at home on
a weekend and he had them play a coin
toss game where every heads that they
tossed, they'd get 20 Swiss francs.
So I think there were 20 coin flips
so you can win up to 400 if you get
magically all, all 20 heads. You were
the one who reported what you got,
so no one would know you're at home.
You can say you've got 20 if you know
that no one would know the difference.
Right. But you know by on average you're
going to get 10 out of 20 heads on the
average. Uh, what he did in this
study was to get them at home,
but for some of them he had them describe
their workplace with their office was
like, so we got them thinking about their
office right before this a game and the
other condition,
they did not do that.
It's the same people randomly assigned
to be the office or the home condition
and you probably can't see this, but
on the left, these are the home people.
They were not asked to
think about their office.
And you get pretty much
the binomial distribution,
which means this is what
you'd expect by chance.
You get some people on the low end,
you get some people on the high end.
But most people are right there,
you know,
four or five or six in the middle or
whatever it is. The, the, at the average,
the people on the right are the people
who thought about their workplace.
It's shifted significantly to the right.
You can get this guy saying, oh yeah,
you know, I got like all
heads are, you know, again,
you've got a lot of heads over there.
Um, and you know, they're greedier,
they're less moral,
they're less honest.
The same people randomly assigned if
they just thought about their office in
this mundane kind of
way, uh, before the task.
And he's talking about situated identities
that you might be a different person
at home, a different values and
different behaviors than you are at, uh,
at your workplace. Unfortunately,
this hack, this actually affects kids.
This is a study that at
the time was shocking,
came out of Harvard about 2004
or five Asian American girls.
Uh, and, uh,
they had them color in a
color of a cartoon, uh,
with crayons that either emphasize
their Asian identity or they're female,
they're girl identity with Asian themes
or with, uh, girls playing with dolls.
Now the stereotype of the culture is
Asian Americans are better at math and
science then everybody else, uh, than
the average person. But girls are not.
Girls are worse at math and
science then everybody else.
So if they had colored in the Asian
American of the Asian themes, the there,
then they took a math test there,
mat test was significantly higher
than the average of the group.
If they had just colored in the girl ones,
their average was significantly lower
than average of the group. Now remember,
they're randomly assigned.
These are the same kids randomly
assigned to be in the Asian or the girl
condition.
The stereotypes of a culture about the
qualities or the capabilities of groups
has already gotten into
their head at age five. Um,
and influencing their actual
performance on a math test.
They are different person depending on
which aspect of their identity has been
made presently salient. So
the future to, to wrap up, um,
the future, your goals change what
you think are good or bad things,
the health risks,
you're willing to take,
who you consider to be your best
friends, uh, and so forth and so on.
There's lots of stuff. I
mean, for me, uh, you know,
th th the feeling of the goal and the
motive is strong when I'm playing these
dumb game apps on my phone and I candy
crush and I'm like trying to beat this
level for weeks and I can't, I almost,
I'm just almost there. And you know,
the in APP purchase, right? These games
are free, but the, in that purchase,
right then that purse, oh, for union $5,
you can get five extra moves like, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. So you, you
beat this level, Yay. And you move on.
And then of course you get the bill.
You know, apple I do at every, you know,
five 99 Dah. As I go, my God, it's like,
well, we'll see the stupid game of Mifa.
Who Cares? No one's going
know is no trophy given out.
And recognition of winning candy crush me,
what am I?
But at the time the goal is so close and
you almost are there and the feeling is
very strong if you really are into this
game and are trying to beat all the
levels,
that kind of thing.
So your goal changes what you think
is as good or bad thing to do. Uh,
in a more important way.
Um, these are, uh, again,
a Dutch grocery store reminded at the
beginning if with a recipe flyer with
words related to healthy eating or dieting
and these are obese shoppers or not, it'd
be shoppers. So now it'll be shoppers.
This PR, these primes and the recipe
fliers do not make any difference on their
purchases.
But if the people who presumably more
likely to have a a dieting goal and on
eating healthy goal,
these words and recipe fliers actually
change how much unhealthy snack food they
buy from B four and 20
euros to one and 80 euros.
And they have no memory
of the recipe flyer,
what was in it and have any idea that
that influenced, influenced them at all.
What they did was activate the goal.
They had four diet and healthy
eating and actually change their,
their purchases when they looked
at the, uh, receipts at the end.
Same thing. This is a university of
Minnesota study, uh, with um, uh,
undergraduate women who say they don't
think diet pills and tanning salons were
a good idea, the health risks
and they're dangerous. Uh,
but if they just looked in Tinder and
other kinds of dating sites and were asked
to rate the attractiveness of both men
and women on the site activating, uh,
like we want to call it a main goal or
the idea of finding a mate and partner or
sex,
whatever you want to call it.
Now they do these ratings
and then suddenly they're
fine with tanning salons and
diet pills and don't think
they're risky at all.
It didn't think they'd hurt them at all.
And so the same people are changed by
the fact that they've got this goal being
attractive as good for that goal.
It may not be good for you and it may
not reflect your chronic or long term
values, but temporarily
you think it's a good idea.
So what's changed you as I said,
these things operate in the background.
They can work on problems that you have
and you maybe you've even forgot about,
uh, what, what it was you're trying
to remember something, you know,
you know it but you can't remember it
and you see here, try, try, try, uh,
to remember it.
And later on you're doing something
completely different three or four hours
later and the answer pops into
your head out of the blue.
But it was because unconsciously you were
still trying to solve that problem in
the background.
You have a goal to solve it.
You really want to solve it and you trying
to figure out that answer and you get
it later when you're thinking
about something else.
Sherlock Holmes did this all the time.
I've read the,
all the novels and the complete short
stories over and over again. When,
when Sherlock Holmes comes to a,
um,
a impasse and can't make progress on
some crime or something he's trying to
solve, he takes a break. It plays
the violin, he takes cocaine,
you did something else and he comes
back his pine trees freshed and he has
insights and he has breakthroughs, right?
He thinks he's, he's refreshed his mind.
What's really going on is while he's, his
conscious mind has been elsewhere, uh,
unconscious processes continue to work
on that problem and sometimes can do a
better job than we can do consciously
for reasons explained in the book,
but reasons for unconscious kinds
of processes being bettered,
a processing information in parallel
and better for complex decisions and
complex problems sometimes and
then more limited focus, uh,
conscious thinking.
Sometimes they come to you and when
you're doing something else like Eureka in
the, in the bathtub running
naked, this is a g rated version,
but he actually was naked according
to historians at the time,
ran naked through the streets of Syracuse
after discovering the principle that
he was working on in a public bath.
And there were,
there have been dreams. The benzene
ring, a ring theory calculate,
came up with a benzene ring theory and
a dream of snake eating each other's
tails and a fiery kind of circle. Uh, I
had my own alligator dream this described,
uh, in the book, but it's the same kind
of experience where it's just, you know,
the answer.
You've been working on something for
five or 10 years and it comes to you in
this kind of dream work,
which is actually another way of
this problem is being worked on,
uh, when you're not actually
consciously thinking about it.
If it's a very important problem as it
was to, um, both, uh, calculate and, uh,
and myself. So people have worried
about these things, uh, in terms of, um,
mine control and,
uh,
whether you can use these
kinds of influences on,
on people to get them to do things that
they maybe didn't want to do on their
own. Um, and so, uh, you know,
we do need to think about and talk about
that because it is something that, um,
that, uh, is it legitimate to worry about.
But just briefly and that's, that's
where I'm going to wrap up. Um, you know,
economist magazine, uh,
worries about mind control, uh,
has issues about that.
In the past,
there been books like communism
hypnotism and the Beatles.
This is actually a book that came out
in 19 seven years old that the Beatles
were trying to hypnotize us and make
us communists through their evil beat.
You can get these on Ebay aluminum foil,
the Fucker beanies that prevent, uh,
aliens from outer space, from sending
rays that influenced your mind. Uh,
and of course the sex
and the ice cube stuff.
There's still books on their subliminal
seduction that had this kind of worry
that that's what's going
on in these kinds of ads.
And this is actually a subliminal ad
that was played on widely during the Bush
Gore campaign in 2000.
This is an actual ad from the Bush
campaign that it was discovered actually
subliminally put the word rats right
before the word Democrats appeared in
September of 2000 trying to emphasize
the rats part of Democrats. Uh,
and they denied it. They meant to do this
and this kind of stuff. And George W.
Bush 43,
uh,
kept denying this for weeks afterwards
saying they don't engage in this
subliminal advertising over
and over again, but they were.
So, you know, those things you
don't really have to worry about.
These on the left are really true.
They really are influencing us outside
of our awareness and our influences that
if we know about them,
we can do something about them and we,
we can actually use them to our advantage.
We can turn them around and,
and have them help us to,
to get done what we want and help us do
the right thing that we want to do and
that kind of thing once we know
all about them. But you know,
some people are insisting that they're
the captain of their soul and the captain
of their ship and none of
those things ever, you know,
everything I influences me,
I'm aware of an eye in town and
nothing else really influences me.
But the really good ship captains are the
ones who take the current and the wind
into account.
They don't just aim their ship at the
port and say that's all that matters.
The current and the wins don't matter
at all because if they do that,
this happens, you get crashed in
the rocks are carried out to sea,
you can play golf.
That way you can aim right at the hole
and fat for Goodwin doesn't matter and
whatever. And this is what happens to you
then. Uh, so you know, it's your choice.
Everyone has the ability to
make that choice on their own.
But really the point is
you actually do have,
we all have control over these things
because they're really not secret anymore.
And once you know about them,
you know,
it's up to you what you want
to do with them. But, uh,
I want to thank you all for coming
and I'm for listening today.
[inaudible]
how could we apply some of these
techniques if I'm trying to lose weight,
how can we apply some of these
techniques to that? For example,
so this is really recent stuff.
The last five or six years,
it's not my area,
but I read the research and every
a researcher now a five, six,
seven of the major researchers in the
area of self control and self regulation,
right,
are saying the people who are effective
self regulators who score high on those
scales,
they people who are good self control,
people on self regulators make more
money than anybody. The rest of us,
they are happier, they have a better
relationships, they're healthier.
All those good things. It comes
with these who are high in this uh,
ability to self regulate and self
control. How did they do it? Well,
the old model is acts of will they have
such a strong will and the rest of us
are just weak willed little wimps and
we can't do the things they can do with
her strong will.
It's actually the opposite of that.
They don't use willpower.
Willpower is hard to do
and it's always a struggle.
What they do is they set up their world
to make it easy for them to do the
things they wanna do.
They set up their environment in a way
that they don't have the tempting things
that they could eat or drink at home. They
don't bio's things in the first place.
They set up the good
things they want to do.
They make good habits out of them
and make routines out of them.
They start by saying, okay, I want
to exercise. I want to go running.
They come home,
they get out of their work clothes and
they immediately put on their running
shorts and running shoes because what
else are you going to do after you put on
your running shoes and you're running
stuff but go run and they make that so
that they do it without even
thinking. They come home, they change,
they put that on and without
having to use any willpower at all.
So the effective self
control and self regulator,
people are making use of the unconscious
kinds of influences of habit and
routine and setting up their world.
If they want to be a kinder and helpful,
they'll put up a photograph of the people
they want to be kind and help to in
their life.
Like their grandmother.
They always are kind and helpful to
their grandmother if they might have a
picture of her on their desk as a reminder
without thinking about it to be that
way or whatever it is, you know,
high achievement, whatever it is.
You make your world to have those cues
come in from the outside that trigger
these tendencies that you want
to support and build your,
your world so that the outside world
supports it instead of terrorists,
those things down and that's what they do.
So that that would apply to a losing
weight. It would apply to exercising.
It would apply to pretty much anything
you want to do. Thanks for the talk.
So shallow,
shallow or final goal.
Be really too on [inaudible] and decipher
unconsciousness as much as we can so
that you can cope with
unconsciousness better.
Or is there some level in which
having some level of unconsciousness,
it's actually a healthy thing and you
should just let let it be Indian? Yeah.
This is the hardest chapter of this book
to write for me was a chapter called
when can you trust your gut? Because
in the past we've had books like blink,
right?
Best sellers that say trust your gut and
other books like thinking fast and slow,
they say don't trust your gut and they're
both sitting there and paper back in
the storage right next to each other,
right? They say the opposite thing.
So it's a little more nuanced than that.
It's a little more difficult
question than that. Uh,
you pretty much can trust your gut and
you can trust unconscious influences,
uh, in, in certain situations
and not in others. Uh,
one rule is if it's your preference and
kinds of things you like or dislike,
your first kind of reactions usually are
the best. And you can overthink your,
your feelings and get something different
because of that and not be as happy
with that choice.
If you overthink it,
you can trust your gut about other people
that you're meeting as long as you see
them in action.
If you see that just the face or you know
their characteristics like skin color
or age and so forth, then you can be very
wrong. But if you see them in action,
usually we're pretty good about that.
So I,
the one thing that the rule for other
people is to always give people a chance.
Don't judge them just on what the
way they look or what you think.
Cause it's very powerful. Studies
in, in courtrooms, for example,
have found that baby faced individuals
have more of a childlike face,
get lower sentences or less likely to
be found guilty for the same crimes as
people who aren't baby faced. And
unfortunately, people of color,
the darker the color, the longer the
sentence they get for the same crime.
And this is going on right now.
This isn't something in the past.
So these things really
matter to real outcomes.
And unfortunately people like judges and
people in legal system deny this stuff
happens. They don't know that that's not
an influence. I just tell my jury not to,
not to be influenced by those
things. Really. That's what,
that's what actual trial judges say
to people who point out this kind of
evidence. So they just said, you know,
so when can you trust unconscious?
I'll tell you one thing. Uh, I heard
from somebody. Um, uh, well anyway,
other people say the same kind of thing.
I was on the channel five a morning
show this morning and somebody in the
audience said the same thing
that I'm going to say now. Um,
I would give myself assignments.
Basically when I'd finished,
I broke this book basically
last year in six months.
I wouldn't try to ride it for four years,
but it finally clicked and I
finally was able, amazing day one,
almost a chapter a week and it just was
coming out of me and what was going on
after I'd finished a chapter. You Think,
oh good, I finished a chapter, you know,
relax, have fun for a while and
then start the next one tomorrow.
But before I would do that,
I always get the next chapter in my head.
I'd always take the next day stuff and
start looking at it and get it all up
here and then go have fun and then go
relax, be with my daughter, you know,
go shopping, do the chores,
whatever I needed to do.
But I'd always get the next thing
in my head first. So it would be,
I'd be working on it without, you know,
unconsciously basically. And boy was,
it was great.
You come back the next day and I'd have
ideas about how to organize and put it
all together and get going right away.
Much better than if you leave it
and start cold the next morning.
So those are the things you kind of use.
One other thing I just,
this is my favorite little tip like life
hat kind of thing out of this is this
thing about bonding and imitation.
You can use that.
It's so easy because we naturally imitate
and mimic each other without trying
to, you don't want to try to, all you
need to do is look at the other person.
So if you're meeting somebody in new
colleague and new work, somebody,
a new neighbor just moved in, you know, a
new friend, you know, anything like that.
Just look at them while you were
interacting for the first time.
You will naturally because
you're just looking at them,
imitate what they do that will naturally
cause them to bond and like with you
more than if you hadn't done that.
And the, the, the, the, the tech,
the trick is just to look at them and
turns out that on, on empathy scales,
people who have a personality is
higher empathic than other people.
They also are the people who look more
and perceive more at the other person
while they're interacting.
And it's a real easy thing to do and it
has all these potentially good benefits
and you're just letting this sort of
unconscious mechanism operate on its own
naturally.
When you say that things
like cooperation and obesity
can have effects two or three
degrees from your social network,
how do you know what's cause
and what's effect? They're like,
how do you know it's not the case?
Dad say obese people tend to be more
friends with each other than otherwise.
Oh,
you can't.
These are correlational studies that the
social network analysis and sociology
is correlational. Uh,
the Facebook study was,
was a actual experimental because they
manipulated the news feed and showed,
but even the earlier Facebook study
showing a contagion were correlational.
That's why Kramer did this second study.
The first one showed the contagion,
but say, well, you know,
the, the objection was just
what you said and then say,
okay,
you experimentally manipulate it.
It was very controversial
because you know,
you're playing around with people's Moods,
right? And it's the end of the user,
the end of the agreement,
what do you call those things?
It's like on page 5,004 that year it was
okay to do that and no one ever reads
those, right? So, uh,
they said it was okay because of the
people using Facebook agreed to this
because it's in the agreement.
Um,
but then they did the experimental
version and showed the same effect.
So you're absolutely right in the
sociological, a social network.
The reason I put that up
there, it's a, it's a,
it's a new method that
shows it actually happening.
It does not give a conclusive
answer about the cause.
The other studies like ours,
when we manipulate what people do and show
the same effect that, that, that helps,
uh, make you feel better
about the causal nature of it.
You have to do both though.
You have to do both kinds of studies
says the mimicry, why everyone
likes parents as a, as a pet bird.
I got a good pair of joke at my,
uh, my real question is that,
so at Google we have a,
well,
we have a lot of training programs around
trying to tackle unconscious biases
and uh, in fact in the promotion
committee processes we have,
everyone's required to go through the
unconscious bias training prior to
actually serving on a promotion
committee. I was just wondering, um,
in the broader, um, uh,
industry with, through uh,
in other corporations, other,
um, other organizations settings,
have you looked into research around a
unconscious bias training and trying to
steer the effects of these,
uh, biases have them,
that is a cottage industry that's
outside of academia basically.
I remember there was a, I look at Tumblr
sometimes and I may have a little dumb,
you know, nature picture thing
on tumbler with three followers.
And since I'm on there like a few Fridays
ago, maybe three or four Fridays ago,
it was an open question and
answer on unconscious bias.
And those people who are
answering the questions,
I don't know any of them
and I haven't heard,
but they're all in the private sector
or the, they're an industry. Uh,
so I don't really know
what the kind of training,
I know that they do talk about the Harvard
implicit IAT kinds of tests that you
can take to detect the fact that you
might have some unconscious bias. Um,
it's a little, uh, it's a,
it's a much simpler version than what
I'm talking about in the book because the
unconscious bias they measure is just
good or bad. It's just you have a,
or a negative association
with these groups and that
that can be mis attributed.
So the idea of this is, this would fall
into the present section of the book,
that you have a negative feeling towards
a member of a different social group
and that negative feeling,
you don't know the real
source of it because it says
unconscious kind of source.
And then you use the attributed to
something that makes plausible sense. Oh,
they didn't have such good letters of
recommendation or they didn't come from a
very good school or you know,
you somehow explain it in some,
in terms of something
that may be plausible.
So that's a real danger is that even well,
meaning well intentioned people,
Egalitarian people fall
prey to this misattribution
effect because they have the
negative feeling not knowing what the
source is and then apply it to something
that is plausible that they can
say, oh, I didn't like this or that.
And makes you know, sense it's not, their
skin color is not their gender, you know?
But there's so many demonstrations.
I mean, in the book,
talk about this new Italian study,
which is horrible.
This is a 11,000 job applications,
actual jobs postings in Italy.
And what they did was they made up a,
an identical set of resumes, identical,
uh, qualifications, education.
Everything is identical.
They either made it a male or
a female applicant by the name,
and they put either an attractive or an
unattractive photograph along with the
application. And they sent all four
to all the 11,000 jobs in Italy.
And these were actual jobs they wanted
to see who got called back for an
interview among the women,
57% of the attractive woman
got called in for an interview.
7% of the unattractive women got called
in for an interview. Now you may say,
well,
they're just intentionally trying to
hire the attractive women and you talk to
the people and no, that's not what we're
trying to do. And that would be illegal.
They don't want to do that.
They say they don't.
And yet they have this bias called the
beauty premium. That's huge. I mean,
57 to 70 for men, it's 47 to 25.
I mean, it's bad for men too,
but for women,
it's gigantic.
And these are people who are not given
the same economic opportunities because
of these kinds of biases. So in
real life right now, you know,
not back in the past, these
things really are a problem. Uh,
and they have to do with biases
that people aren't aware of.
But now we should know
more about these biases.
And we should be able to take
steps to stop them. You know,
like not having photographs on
applications for one thing. Right?
And I know an orchestra's, uh,
the tryouts are behind a curtain.
You don't know the age, you don't know
the gender, you don't know the race,
the ethnicity, whatever you want to call
it, of the person behind the curtain.
You can only hear the music.
If we could do that.
And that's easy to do for orchestras,
right?
It's not yet easy to do in other areas,
but removing those kinds of
cues that the culture gives us,
it says this group can do this,
this group can't do that. You know,
we get from the culture
and soaks into all of us.
Even if we are well meaning and well
intentioned and egalitarian people,
it's still in our heads. We'd get rid
of those cues. We'd be a lot better off.
We can do a lot more now. I don't
know if that's what they do. See,
I don't know the training and,
and what they're about.
But that would be my
answer or my solution or,
but I would suggest based
on the research now what we
do here is, uh, it,
it depends on if you're taking the online
version of the training or if you're
doing the, um, the, the in
person training sessions.
But the in person training sessions
tried to really focus on, um,
trying to incite these biases,
trigger these biases that someone might
not realize that they have and say,
then you can reflect on,
on having,
on realizing that you had
that bias that you didn't
it because I, I have so strongly, I mean,
this is why I went into my field partly,
and I teach this about Yale
undergraduates and everything.
And I do get some students walking out
of the room talking about these kinds of
things about privilege and stuff like
that. Uh, but here's what I would say,
because I've got your right
now and I'm gonna say this,
the last chapter of the book, and I'll
give it to you for free right now.
What I'm saying.
It's not my own research,
but just a way to combat these
things that actually works.
They're called implementation
intentions and not my race.
My colleague Peter Goldwood Cert Nyu.
The idea is this,
when I see a person of color,
I will be fair and what you're doing is
you're specifying the trigger out there
that will cause the idea of
fairness immediately to happen. You,
you link your intention to the,
into the future state of affairs.
When I see a person of color,
which is going to happen,
I will be fair and you, you really
have to commit yourself to that.
It's not a magic trick that if you
don't really, I don't really care about,
I'll say it. You know, magic magic.
It's not a, it's not a magic spell.
You have to be really committed in the
first place, but you want to do that.
You can say that and actually it works
and that works for lots of things.
You know, when x happens in a reliable
future event, that always happens.
I will do y when x happens,
I will do y and that kind of thing helps.
The elderly,
take medications when they
got five different kinds
of pills at different times
of day with food or without food.
All this kind of complicated stuff.
It helps them do that. It helps health
psychology is we use this political, uh,
people have used this to increase voter
turnout in primary elections because
they say at 10 o'clock on Tuesday morning,
I will take a break from work,
I will drive to the polling place.
And I, you specify the when,
where and how of you're going to take a
carry out your intention instead of I'm
just going to vote. You make
a concrete plan when, where,
and how I'm going to do it. And that
really helps. So if there can be a,
when the feisty of encounter a
person of color, I will be fair,
that simple kind of thing.
And they've actually done studies showing
that actually does make people more
fair and treatment.
So maybe that'll work.
So I've been told, I have
the honor of asking the last
question. And My, uh, so you,
earlier you mentioned the experiment where
if people were exposed to warm a warm
environment,
there were more prone to social warm and
if they were exposed to colder than the
opposite,
uh,
do you know if that is a function
of people using the exact same word,
warm to refer to these two very different
things or versus like social warmth
then acts, physical warmth as,
so, thank you for asking. Asking
that.
Uh,
it's the reason why we use the word
warm for both and there's lots of George
Lake off right at Berkeley has written
all about metaphors we live by and all
these different metaphors.
We tend to appropriate a physical language
terms to talk about our relationship
with people. It's almost like there's
no psychology separate language.
It's all physical.
So we talk about a distant father or
a close relationship or high status.
These are all physical direction, you
know, uh, kinds of terms. A warm friend,
a cold friend, a cold boss,
you know, something like that.
So why are we using all
these physical terms?
Because it turns out these are
researchers who look at child language
development.
It turns out these are
the first experiences that
children have and their direct
experiences. They're the first concept
infants forum and kids, toddlers, former,
these warm called high, low, you
know, close and far kinds of terms,
rough, smooth, and so our then we
develop understandings of people.
We tend to use that vocabulary and so we
talk about a hard negotiator or soft on
crime.
Okay.
Which means when we're yielding,
you know,
it's the physical term
all the time and we just,
we all know what each other means to,
we can communicate using these terms.
The thing about the warm,
I just want to say no,
how many of you are parents are going to
be parents, but this channel of warmth,
a physical warm signaling to the infant
that you can trust that the infant can
trust. Whoever they're with
is gigantic. It's, it's,
it's been there since time in memorial
and it's a way that, you know,
now my wife used to work in a hospital.
They say,
she says now that they have the father
opened the shirt and put the baby on on
the fathers,
just not just the mother breastfeeding
because I want the father to also bond
with the child and they say this is
the skin on skin contact, Eh, eh,
it may not be the skin on skin as much
as the warmth because to the baby who
doesn't know anything,
the feeling of warmth is an ancient of
sign that you can be trusted and is this
channel that works all the way through
our life. It's still there as adults,
but it's hugely important for the
infant who doesn't know who to trust is
totally helpless,
is dependent on everybody around
them to keep them fed and warm and,
and uh, have something to drink and
shelter protected from predators.
And it's that channel.
So I knew this going in with my daughter.
I hugged and hugged and hugged and
hugged and hugged to make sure she was as
securely attached by age
one at least as possible.
I was basically a single parent raising
this little girl and knowing that it
would affect her the rest of her life,
it would affect her
friendships and great school.
How long her relationships lasted in
her twenties and if I could just invest,
even though it's so exhausting,
you know, with little, little,
little babies and toddlers is invest
as much as my time to do that for her.
Early on, it would pay off her her
forever and we can all do that.
But that channel is there and it can be
used. It seems irrational. It seems silly.
Why would warm, you know, but the
little, no, nothing baby. It matters.
It matters everything. Thank you
very much. Thanks for the question.
[inaudible].